[MUSIC]
Somewhere between when we're a baby and
when we're a fully functioning
member of society, we come to reach
a decision about what we're capable of.
When I go around the world
asking the question,
who's a great leader,
people bring up names from Gandhi,
great political leaders in history,
JFK and the like.
The ones who come to mind when
you think about people you admire
is that they are known for continuing
their development throughout their lives.
Clearly, there's a developmental process.
And yet at some point, we come to
the conclusion that there are some things
we can do and some things we can't do.
[MUSIC]
These exceptional leaders were not born
exceptional, and they didn't know a thing.
They became something over their life.
And the question is,
can you become something over your life?
Write down something you want to do
to develop yourself personally in
terms of development and growth mindset?
Write down something that you would
like to do that would make you better at
affecting others in your organization
that way, creating a context for
others to flourish.
And write down a change that you could
make in yourself that you think would
impact the broader environment.
Make them your personal commitment
to develop yourself at all three of
these levels.
[MUSIC]
>> Question your assumptions and
explore new approaches to leadership.
Explore Stanford's upcoming programs.
[MUSIC]